خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود ملك المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
رئيس الدوره الثانيه والثلاثين لمجلس
جامعه الدول العربيه على مستوى القمه
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
معاني الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
ضيوف القمه العربيه الكرام والحضور الكريم
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اطيب لي في مستهل هذا الجمع المبارك
ان انقل لكم تحيات حضره صاحب الجلاله
سلطان هيثم بن طارق المعظم سلطان عمان
وتمنياته الصادقه ودعمه ومساندته لاعمال
القمه العربيه الثانيه والثلاثين
على ارض المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
برئاسه اخاه خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز
والذي بحكمته واخوانه قالت الدول العربيه
نرى في سلطنه عمان
وبالتوفيق من الله سبحانه وتعالى بان نجاح
هذه القمه قد تحقق بالتئام
شمل الامه
العربيه ولله الحمد والفضل
الشكر والتحيه لجهود خادم الحرمين
الشريفين المخلصه
والمبادرات الناجحه ولاخوانه من القاده
العرب في سبيل احياء التضامن العربي
وانهاء زمات المنطقه بحلول عربيه
والمضي الى مرحله مشرقه في مسيره الامه
بما يعود بمشيئه الله بالنفع على دولنا
وشعوبنا وامتنا العربيه
ودون شك على غيرنا من الدول العالم
من دول العالم لما يمثله عالمنا العربي من
ثقل هام على مستوى العالم
ولا يفوتنا هنا ان نعرب عن شكرنا لمعالي
احمد بن الغيط لمين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه والجهاز الامانه العامه على
جهودهم في التحضيرات المثمره لهذه القمه
ودورهم البناء في تطوير منظومه العمل
العربي المشترك
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمور وسائل
الوفود
لقد اكد يراط سلطان هيثم بن طارق سلطان
عمان في اول خطاب بعد توليه الحكم
بالاستمرار في دعم جامعه الدول العربيه
والتعاون مع زعماء الدول العربيه والرقي
بحياه المواطنين والني بهذه المنطقه عن
الصراعات والخلافات
والعمل على تحقيق تكامل اقتصادي يخدم
تطلعات الشعوب العربيه
ومن تلكم العبادي والغايات فيسعدنا ان
نرحب باستئناف مشاركه الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه الشقيقه
الفاعله في اعمال جامعه الدول العربيه
معربين عن الارتياح لحضور ومشاركه فخامه
الرئيس بشار الاسد في هذه القمه مع اليقين
التام بان سوريا الشقيقه
ستستعيد بعون الله وبعزمه رجالا رجلها
ونسائها وشبابها مكانتها كحاضره تاريخيه
ومنار عربيه مشهود لها بذلك
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والسمور وسائل وهول
اننا في سلطنه عمان وكغيرنا من الدول
والشعوب المحبه للعدل والسلام
نعتقد بان عجز المجتمع الدولي يعني جاد
تسويه عن التسويه العادله والمنصه
والمنصفه لمعانات الشعب الفلسطيني هو منبع
التوترات التي تعصف من حين الاخر
بالمنطقه والعالم
اذ لا يمكن ان نامل نامل بمستقبل للشعوب
يكمن في التعايش والاستقرار دون تطبيق
مبادئ ومعايير القانون الدولي
وقرارات الشرعيه الدوليه تجاه القضيه
الفلسطينيه
ومنح حق الشعب الفلسطيني
باقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه المستقله
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه وعلى خطوط الرابع
مليون يورو
1967 وفقا لقرارات مجلس الامن الصادره في
هذا الشان مبادره السلام العربيه ومبدا
الارض مقابل السلام
اننا على يقين تام بان الحفاظ على جامعه
الدول العربيه وتطويرها سيعزز من على
التعاون والتكامل
وتبادل المنافع فيما بين دولنا وكذلك مع
مختلف دول العالم
مستلهمين الموروث الحضاري للامه العربيه
والتاريخ التليد وما قدمته للبشريه في
مختلف العلوم والمعارف
ولنؤكد حقنا باننا قادرون بكلمه سوى على
ان نخطوا بانفسنا والرقي بدولنا الى افاق
ارحب
ازدهارا ونماء والمضي بشعوبنا الى مكانتها
اللائقه بين الامم
وختاما يسرنا ان نتقدم بجزيل الشكر
والتقدير الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه وحكومه حكومه وشعبا على حسن
الاستقبال وكرم الضيافه وعلى حسن التنظيم
لنجاح هذه القمه السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات